well as there was a bit Clark sat down
with Bangladesh's prime minister Sheikh
Hasina Nick asked her what the future
holds for rohingya refugees
when this incident
started
and people were tortured molar then
raped so many things happen
actually
we feel very bad then we open our door
to influx them we allowed them to come
and we make all the arrangement for
shelter treatment all these things on
human to turn ground
side by side we started talking to
Myanmar also that this they are your
citizen you should take them back
Unfortunately they are not responding
very positively I feel that um
these people should go back to their own
land own home
but it's impossible because the security
situation and as you say Myanmar you
can't even talk to them well in the
International Community they are putting
pressure on them then but it's really
very difficult
we have arranged accommodation in a
separate place that is a good
placed on good accommodation in
vashanchol is it a good place it's very
overcrowded and it's no no
very good place and the good uh housing
and the
good harassment for the children but
what about the living conditions
generally because this fire has just
taken place and and thousands 12 000
plus and now displaced in public
actually now in the camp in Cox's but
our situation is not very good but now
they have started fighting with each
other they indulge in different type of
activities like drug trafficking arm
trafficking human trafficking and also
they have their own conflicts but this
war become
more difficult because the whole focus
is now
on the war and the refugee from Ukraine
and you can watch the whole interview
with the Bangladeshi prime minister
Sheikh Hasina on talk to Al Jazeera
that's at 4 30 GMT on the 11th of March